the international community of committee
of the red cross says it has not been
granted access to the bombed outside of
a prison camp where dozens of ukrainian
prisoners of war were killed in a
missile strike
russia's defense ministry says it has
invited the red cross and the un to
inspect the location following calls
from ukraine for an investigation moscow
and kiev have blamed each other for the
soldiers deaths
now elsewhere in ukraine heavy russian
strikes hit the southern port city of
mikaliv killing a leading businessman in
the grain export business and injuring
several other people
now dw's matthias berlinga is in odessa
for us matthias
first the attack of the prisoner of war
camp russia says it's invited the un and
the red cross in
will they be allowed to investigate
freely
well it's not an investigation mission
as far as we know it's a mission to
establish uh the identity of those who
were killed and to
uh
yeah
and to help with medical supplies etc
it's not an investigation into what has
happened there however we have this
invitation from the russians via public
channels but the red cross is saying it
has not yet received confirmation that
they'll be really able to travel here so
we don't know whether it will really
happen or not
okay and and we're also hearing from
turkey that the first
grain export shipment could leave
ukraine on monday but with the renewed
attacks in southern ukraine is that
likely
i'm not sure whether there's a link
between these attacks and these grain
exports because uh
these attacks have been going on for
quite a while and they have started
before that grain deal was signed the
attacks on nikolayev i'm saying mcclive
is one of the cities that has been
shelled heavily since the beginning of
the war what is true is that the these
shellings have intensified throughout
the past few days and uh that the last
night was probably the worst one of the
worst if not the worst uh since the
beginning of the war with 40 rockets
hitting the city so um these
uh shellings have clearly intensified
there has also been have also been
explosions here in odessa in the
outskirts of odessa
and that's also something that has
occurred during the past few days weeks
you can see behind me that people have
somehow adapted to this and they're not
disrupted by
by something hitting somewhere in the
outskirts or nearby but of course there
is always the danger and i think if uh
these strikes would not directly hit the
ports right now where these ships are
already loaded and waiting to leave that
would probably not be a disruption
ukraine has no interest in in
in using these attacks in some way they
have an interest in getting out as much
grain as possible as long as it will be
possible faith is not very high that
this will really work on the longer
period four or eight months needed to
get all the grain supplies out and
that's definitely something that um
many people have doubts about whether
this will really be possible so whether
it's going to happen tomorrow or not we
don't know the signal the go has to come
from turkey from this coordination
center it did not come on friday and
saturday as many had expected but it
might come tomorrow
you